você já parou pra observar o ambiente
que circunda você com a natureza ou a
falta dela que consegue fazer a trama da
sua vida ou seja para perceber os fios
culturais que moldam a sua ação no mundo
eu peço para vocês um pequeno tempo para
que vocês consigam serenamente imaginar
o que acabei de falar
imagine hoje imagina pontes imaginar os
carros os sinais às avenidas os prédios
imaginar os sons barulho o ritmo da
cidade
o cheiro os sabores
vocês conseguem perceber que essa soma
de coisas forma um quadro na tua vida
mas se vocês perceberem com mais atenção
vocês verão que falta uma coisa falta a
aventura aventura que traz os desafios
o novo o incerto o arriscado os desafios
que fazem com que a tua vida mulher mude
como humanos
a gente precisa dessas três coisas da
natura da cultura e da aventura isso
modela e faz com que a gente se
movimente de forma tão bela e tão bonita
como a gente faz na vida que a gente tem
agora imagine todas as aventuras
mesmo aquelas bem pequenas que vocês já
tiveram as suas vidas
aquela vez em que você sentiu adrenalina
percorrendo o teu corpo aquele medo
aquela vontade de ir em frente mas sem
saber se ia ou se ficava em que você foi
em frente à uerj com você partiu por
certo que você de alguma mão de alguma
de algum modo de alguma maneira foi
feliz
essa sensação perta perto do perigo
cria na gente
essa vontade e esse desejo de ir além
mas a gente não pode fazer isso nas
aventuras se usar a nossa inteligência
eu particularmente tive muitas vivências
muitas experiências entre natura
esculturas e aventuras diferentes
eu pude ver semelhanças e diferenças em
diversos lugares onde vive
seja no rio de janeiro seja na paraíba
seja no pará seja na alemanha e seja
quem recebeu
lembro dos vários desafios em que eu
precisei usar a minha capacidade de ir
além de desafiar mais usando a
inteligência necessária para conseguir
resolver os problemas e os desafios que
lá aconteceu e de que com cada desafio
eu tinha que usar um modo diferente para
resolver o que eu precisava
certa vez eu estava na alemanha
essa história eu gosto muito de contar
eu tinha acabado de chegar na alemanha
fui visitar uma tia e eu fui aprendendo
alemão durante o vôo recife e frankfurt
as únicas as coisas que eu mais aprendi
durante esse vôo foi contar de 1 a 10 ea
primeira coisa que eu fiz quando cheguei
na alemanha
fui perguntar pra minha tia
como se como se falava pão e cerveja
porque estava com medo de passar fome
sede na alemanha e logo que eu cheguei
me juntei com os amigos e eles quiseram
me levar para uma cidade chamada till
bin que ficava a cerca de 500
quilômetros da cidade da minha tia e
ficava perto de franco e eu fui passei
uma semana com eles e na volta era um
domingo decide voltar pra casa da minha
tia e decidiu fazer sozinho na alemanha
tudo muito tranquilo você compra a
passagem e vem um mapa de viagem
a questão é que eu não eu decidi
arriscar
eu não peguei os três mais rápidos e que
me levaram pra casa em 32 horas e meia a
três horas
resolvi pegar um outro ticket que
levariam uma infinidade de tempo e vejo
as 34 do exemplo de 63 horas
eu levaria 6 8 horas em que fariam um
traçado muito maior mas eu estava com
planos de viagem então tudo tranquilo
só que não uma dessas mudanças
determinadas estações de trem
o mapa dizia e junho os amigos tinham
anotado que eu precisaria de ser uma
estação sair dessa estação e pegar um
bonde
essa cidade se chamava airbag eu tinha
que descer na estação de rádio bem sair
da estação e pegar um bronze
até aí tudo bem também a questão é que
haydn albergue fica entre manhattan e me
evanna raiva e raiva
logicamente e fui parar e fui a caminho
de manhattan mas alguma coisa me
angustiou apesar de não conseguir
conversar com ninguém eu só sabia de um
a 10 pão e cerveja e mais algumas coisas
eu não consegui entender muita coisa não
estava inscrito mas eu sentia que alguma
coisa estava errada e eu dou nada decide
descer na primeira estação que eu achei
que deveria eu desci no meio do nada na
campanha eu não saber não sabia bem a
língua
eu não conhecia ninguém eu não tinha uma
cabine telefônica e ninguém estava
naquela naquela estação naquele de bonde
mas eu fiquei algum tempo tentando ver
como é que resolver aquela situação tava
no meio de uma aventura até que surgiram
2 a 1
e aí eu sem falar alemão direito ele sem
falar inglês nem português
a gente vai tentando se entender e eles
me disseram que eu estava no lugar
errado e que eu deveria ir para uma
outra estação e pegar um trem correto um
bonde correto
foi o que eu fiz e conseguir chegar em
wana raio mas eu perdi toda minha roda
todas as minhas conexões já tinham ido
embora
novamente estava em uma estação com
pouco dinheiro e sem ninguém para tirar
uma dúvida
foi quando decidi ligar pra minha tia e
desse dia e eu tô aqui na cidade de wana
é topo pelo que eu vi aqui há uns 350
quilômetros em você mas eu vou tentar
dar um jeito de chegar o mais próximo
possível da sua cidade e se possível se
vocês puderem pegar
do outro lado da linha e ouvia muito
amavelmente a minha tia fazendo com o
esposo dela
e ai ai mudam de forma muito amorosa
estavam discutindo que eu deveria ou não
ficar ali mas eu disse olha eu vou eu
vou dar um jeito aqui e vou ver o que
acontece
eram três da tarde eu conseguir refazer
a rota
peguei um comprei um dicionário de
alemão e comecei a falar alemão
dali mesmo o máximo dela é bom que podia
é e com isso eu consegui chegar na minha
cidade eu cheguei à meia noite eu
cheguei maravilhado por aquela
experiência primeiro porque tinha dado
certo
segundo porque minha capacidade de
absorção para o alemão aumentou
exponencialmente eu senti meu coração ea
mente expandido de uma forma muito
agigantada
minha tia ficou impressionada e o meu o
esposo dela ficou impactado como é que
um cara com pouco domínio da língua num
país distante consegue resolver coisas
dessa forma
é isso me gerou uma vontade imensa e
depois repeti várias e várias vezes de
viajar pela alemanha e quase que
propositalmente e perder
e cada vez que eu perdi a minha mãe mas
eu me achava cada vez que eu viajava
sozinho e tentava fazer novos amigos
melhor eu aprendia a língua alemã e fui
o meu melhor e mais maravilhoso curso de
línguas estrangeiras que eu tive
por essas e outras experiências depois
eu fui percebendo eu tinha uma
capacidade e uma atração muito forte
coisas que eram incertas arriscadas ou
desconhecidas e percebe que pelo fato de
eu estar sempre perto dessas coisas
isso me instigava muito e gerava uma
adrenalina muito forte na do corpo e me
instigava a ir além a sair daquela
circunscrição que a natureza ou a
cultura daquele local e impunha
eu queria sempre está em aventura é e aí
isso também gerou em mim é uma um
desapareceu lamento por rotinas padrões
e aquele dia a dia muito maçante
algum tempo depois eu volto ao brasil e
decidiu fazer psicologia
eu queria entender como é que encara as
que tinham vivenciado em grandes ou
maiores proporções até em menores
proporções
esse fato de estar sempre perto do
incerto do riscado do desconhecido
como é que eles conseguiram gerar
impacto e aí eu comecei o curso de
psicologia
nessa busca quem são esses caras como é
que os caras vivem de ana de nazaré
como é que eles vão se transformou e aí
eu fui estudando criatividade superação
e percepções novos comportamentos e como
determinadas pessoas
dão um grande sentido na sua vida e
nesse caminhar nessa trajetória eu
cheguei até a inovação que é quando
alguém busca superar fazendo aquilo que
não sabia não conhecia mas estava
disponível e disposto a quebrar as
regras ou quebrar as coisas
estabelecidas e principalmente faziam
isso não só para si mas faziam isso a
sua família a sua comunidade a sociedade
e para várias e várias outras pessoas
fiquei apaixonado por inovação a paixão
avassaladora
eu não conseguia pensar mais em outra
coisa
tanto que eu terminei meu curso não foi
trabalhar na clínica não foi trabalhar
na escola não trabalha em recursos
humanos e fui procurando um lugar para
trabalhar com inovação até que consegui
uma vaga experimental no instituto
inovação aqui em recife
juntando tudo isso ea experiência que eu
tinha tido das várias vários encontros e
desencontros das várias aventuras e
desventuras de estar sempre próximo de
da natureza as culturas aventuras
diferentes distintas em que eu precisava
sempre está buscando algo que eu não
tinha dentro de mim mesmo para superar
desafios
eu fui juntando também tudo isso com as
coisas que naturalmente eu ia recolhendo
pelo meio do caminho como livros artigos
e textos que naquele momento às vezes
não fazem o menor sentido da minha vida
mas que após algum tempo começaram a
mostrar que eu já tinha uma internação
para estudar e perceber aquilo tudo mas
que eu não usava de forma efetiva e
simplesmente estava vivenciando
experimentando aquela experiência
e aí eu saí juntando tudo principalmente
no último ano e comecei a perceber as
correlações que eu comecei eu tinha
começado a fazer de coisas como freud e
jung entre sonhos inconsciente coletivo
entre um cara chamado antônio store e um
domenico de masi
quem fala sobre pessoas originais e
grupos criativos passando por um cara
chamado por terra pai e um outro chamado
leonardo me love que fala de códigos
culturais e hábitos repetitivos também
de um cara chamado mais mal com goldman
e nicolas nassim taleb que fala de
pessoas fora de série empreendedores
fora de série ea capacidade televisão em
que às vezes as pessoas estão travadas e
incluindo o raul morgado né que falar
das inteligências múltiplas e juntando
tudo isso em inovação eu quis perceber
claramente como é que os empreendedores
usavam as suas inteligências a sua
capacidade de ir além de criar novos
sentidos e se apaixonar por aquilo que
estavam que estavam ou estariam fazendo
e como é que pessoas conseguem com suas
inteligências suas paixões criar novos
sentidos criar novas coisas e que isso
depois se alastra por pela sociedade
como um todo e as várias inteligências
as várias formas como as pessoas usam
seus talentos ou inteligência seja
linguística corporal abstrata lógica
matemática musical como é que cada um
tem sua singularidade e resolve um
problema em uma maneira muito específica
e como é que consegue entrar no incerto
extrair uma oportunidade e trazer de
volta para o mundo um sentido o que tem
importado para mim nesses últimos dez
anos mas principalmente no último ano é
poder trabalhar junto com essas pessoas
descobrindo elas tentando resgatar
algumas outras e fazendo com que a gente
e elas principalmente gera um impacto
que possam colaborar e construir uma
nova sociedade uma sociedade com muito
má
sentido proativo colaborar aqui
concientizar esses empreendedores têm
sido minha minha grande paixão é como o
espírito do rock disse
ele fala que a inteligência é a
capacidade de se adaptar às mudanças e
eu pego também um trecho de um cara
chamado me rali recente ml
um cara como eu chamado mas o caps que
não pode errar o nome desse mas é o nome
dele é pior que o meu
é ele fala que se adaptar a mudanças é
estarem fluxo é usar todo seu potencial
de forma intensa decidida e com prazer a
fim de ter sucesso em uma atividade
sugerem uma paixão avassaladora e
contínuo
eu tenho sentido isso de forma muito
intensa e isso tem feito muito sentido
na minha vida
atualmente a minha busca tem sido ver as
pessoas a buscar conversar com elas e
perguntar você tem coragem de avaliar a
tua natureza a sua cultura e decidir
quais as suas novas aventuras
você tem capacidade você tem paixão
o que está faltando para você seguir em
frente
boa tarde